et le débat de ce club des territoires
consacré au trafic de drogue longtemps
cantonnée dans les grandes villes et
leur périphéries il s'étend désormais au
villes moyennes et aux petites villes
comment expliquer ce phénomène comment
lutter c'est l'objet de ce débat avec
nous pour en parler Véronique Guillotin
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes sénatrice RDSE de
Meurthe-et-Moselle et vous étiez jusqu'à
il y a peu concerne municipal de
Villepreux et vous êtes originaire
d'ailleurs de Villerupt ville où une
fusillade au trafic de drogue a fait 5
BC il y a plusieurs jours on va y
revenir Mathieu Valley bonjour merci
d'être avec nous par parole du syndicat
indépendant des commissaires de police
et Michel gondillon bonjour merci d'être
avec nous membres du Conseil
d'orientation scientifique de
l'Observatoire des criminalités
internationales et auteurs de ce livre
qu'on va voir drugstore la France des
trafics c'est aux éditions du Cerf avant
d'entamer ce débat Audrey on va avoir
avec vous un point sur la situation il
n'y a pas que des cas isolés en France
les petites les villes les petites
villes les villes moyennes sont elles
aussi concernées par le trafic de drogue
oui avec des exemples particulièrement
violents vous l'avez évoqué il y a 15
jours il a eu cinq blessés dont trois
graves dans un règlement de compte sur
fond de stup à villeruptes en
Meurthe-et-Moselle frontière
luxembourgeoise je vous apprends rien
madame la sénatrice ville Rupe c'est
9500 habitants mais d'autres villes ont
récemment défrayé à la chronique en
matière de drogue Cavaillon dans le
Vaucluse 27000 habitants ou encore
Villefranche-de-Rouergue dans l'Aveyron
12000 habitants Oriane ce qu'il faut
savoir est-ce que j'ai appris en
réalisant cette chronique c'est qu'avec
5 millions de consommateurs de cannabis
notre pays constituent le premier pays
consommateur en Europe ce sont les
chiffres de l'Observatoire français des
drogues et des toxicomanies on observe
aussi une montée en puissance de l'herbe
dont la consommation a augmenté de 40%
depuis 20 ans et la consommation de la
cocaïne elle a été multipliée par 6
comme il y a des clients l'offre se
multiplient d'après le ministère de
l'Intérieur notre pays compte plus de
4000 points de Deal répartis partout sur
le territoire je vais vous montrer une
carte qui représente les pointes d'îles
par département alors on retrouve
évidemment en noir là où il y en a le
plus où il y a des grandes villes Paris
on pense à l'Île-de-France aussi les
Bouches-du-Rhône mais regardez jaune en
orange et en gris ce sont des
départements moins peuplés où l'on
compte quand même entre 25 et 75 x 2
points de Deal pardon Oriane merci
Audrey pour ce point Michel Gandillon
est-ce qu'on constate une augmentation
du trafic de drogue dans le pays et une
nouvelle répartition de ce trafic
à une forte augmentation du marché des
drogues depuis une vingtaine d'années en
France effectivement entre 2000 et
2017-2020 la consommation de cannabis a
augmenté de plus de 40%, les usages de
cocaïne d'ecstasie drogues de synthèse
on était multiplié par 4 ou 5 on a on
est le premier marché du cannabis en
Europe en volume en tout cas avec 5
millions de consommateurs 600 000
usagers dans l'année donc il est bien
évident qu'avec une telle progression
des consommations et des usages une
offre s'organise en face pour répondre
effectivement à cette demande
et d'après le ministère de l'Intérieur
Audrey l'a dit il y a 4000 points de
deal sur tout le territoire est-ce
qu'ils sont comment ils sont répartis
est-ce qu'il y a des zones est-ce qu'il
y a des régions où c'est pandine sont
plus nombreux oui en fait si vous voulez
on a la carte que vous avez montré qui
est très pertinente on a des points de
vie avant qu'il y a 20 ans été concentré
dans les grandes agglomérations les
grandes villes les grands ensembles la
banlieue parisienne des Bouches-du-Rhône
le Nord mais aussi l'ouest au niveau par
exemple de Rennes ou Nantes aujourd'hui
on voit qu'il y a plus aucun territoire
qui était Parné par ces trafics ça c'est
exporté il y a une telle demande de
consommateur et de consommation que en
fait les trafiquants viennent au cœur de
là où il y a de la demande à Cavaillon
mais aussi à Valence mais aussi à
Besançon avec ce quartier de la Planoise
qui aujourd'hui en reconquête
républicaine ça mot très fort pour dire
qu'on avait perdu du territoire avec les
policiers
galèrent si j'ose dire chaque jour pour
récupérer face au dealer face au
trafiquant face finalement à ces petites
mains du réseau de pouvoir récupérer du
terrain et en fait la consommation c'est
accrue que le trafic s'est étendu sur le
territoire et en plus si vous voulez les
mêmes techniques qu'on connaît dans les
grandes villes comme Marseille puisque
on est quasiment à 22 morts depuis le
début de l'année avec les règlements de
comptes s'exporte en fait dans ces
petites et moyennes vies par exemple à
Villerupt lorsque il y a eu ces
règlements de comptes qu'on a constaté
qui a fait l'année d'actualité mais
aussi à Avignon lorsqu'on va dans ces
quartiers où on a des règlements de
compte si vous voulez ce qu'inquiète les
services de police c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on a des armes de guerre qui circulent
de plus en plus facilement non plus
uniquement dans les grands ensembles
mais dans ces petites et moyennes villes
les policiers notamment de la police
judiciaire font régulièrement des
saisies des interpellations pour lutter
contre la criminalité organisée et puis
on a plus ces bandits il y a 30 ans ou
40 ans qui avait des codes d'honneur qui
avait un passif de voyou et qui
finalement était facilement identifiés
aujourd'hui on a des individus de plus
en plus jeunes notamment des mineurs une
main d'oeuvre qui est uniquement locale
et qui vient aussi des autres
départements parce que les policiers les
connaissent moins et parce qu'ils sont
plus difficiles identifiables et surtout
ce qui nous inquiète c'est que les
litiges commerciaux si j'ose dire ou la
dispute entre les gangs ou entre les
mafia parce que c'est des néo mafia se
règle à coup d'enlèvement de
séquestration de Barb essayer de torture
de barbecue vous savez ces individus qui
sont enlevés et brûler vivre dans les
coffres de voiture donc on a aujourd'hui
une mexicanisation en fait du trafic de
stupéfiant en France et c'est ça qui
inquiète les services de police vous
prenez je termine on va y revenir en
détail on va en parler les profils de
ceux qui commettent des assassinats ou
des tentatives d'assassinats sont très
inquiétants il faut froid dans le dos on
a des individus très jeunes 17 18 19 ans
qui ne sont pas connus des services de
police et de justice donc il passe à
travers nos radars qui bénéficient de ce
totem d’immunité c'est à dire que
souvent ils sont primodénacents on les a
pas identifié avant on les a pas tracés
et qui ont un rivalisé en fait pour 2030
000 euros si des individus que des
commanditaires à l'étranger leur donnent
comme objectif ce film et puis diffuse
leur forfait en fait sur les réseaux
sociaux comme snapchat comme les boucles
telegrammes et ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qu'un cas de ces services de
police et de justice et on va y revenir
en détail Véronique Guillotin est-ce que
vous attendiez à ce qu'une ville comme
la vôtre Villerupt qui est pas une
grande ville moins de 10000 habitants
soit touché par un tel phénomène touché
par le phénomène de drogue et
toxicomanie oui c'est toutefois connu
touché par une telle violence non ça a
été alors à la fois surprenant et à la
fois on entendait les gens dire on n'est
pas surpris donc oui la violence des
faits cette fusillade en pleine rue en
plein centre c'est pas un quartier dit
c'est pas des ce sont pas des barres
d'immeubles on est sur un passage entre
une zone un parc pour enfants le marché
l'arrêt de bus et moi j'appelle ça un
supermarché à ciel ouvert quoi donc oui
ça a été lui ça a été choquant sidérant
et pas sur
Couleur coureur il y avait ce point de
vie depuis des mois mais ça ça entre
guillemets j'ai comme le sentiment que
c'était dans le paysage donc je vois
qu'il y a des des tarifs on avait des
tarifs effectivement qui étaient sur les
murs voilà et puis il y a eu des signes
avant-coureurs et c'est exactement ce
que vous disiez c'était plutôt sur ce
fond là de vengeance de séquestration
entre deux bandes qui n'étaient pas des
bandes exportées sont des jeunes locaux
en fait qui un kidnappé l'autre violenté
matraqué mis sur les réseaux humiliés du
coup et il y a eu cette réponse qui a
été cette réponse là et cette réponse là
pas mal de gens s'y attendaient parce
que c'est aussi passé sur les réseaux
avec des armes automatiques même sur une
ville de 10000 habitants et vous dites
ce sont des jeunes locaux on va y
revenir parce que ça veut dire que c'est
pas le trafic des grandes villes qui
s'est exportées dans des petites villes
ça veut dire que ce sont d'autres
consommateurs alors d'abord les
consommateurs qui avant venaient de ces
petits et moyennes villes qui allaient
s'alimenter dans les grandes villes et
exactement aujourd'hui le fond à
domicile et puis vous savez les dealers
les trafiquants et ceux qui vendent de
la drogue sont pas plus bêtes que les
autres ils estiment qu'il y a des
marchés à conquérir dans des territoires
qui étaient plus ou moins épargnés il y
a parfois vous prenez Cavaillon il y a
20 ans c'était une ville tranquille
paisible avec quasiment aucun trafic
aujourd'hui si vous avez ce qu'on
appelle des fours tellement ils sont
actifs et chauds avec 80000 euros par
oldimum qui va être apporté par le
trafic de stupéfiants aujourd'hui c'est
ça aussi qui inquiète les autorités et
les policiers et les magistrats et le
grand drame de civil comme villedrude
comme Cavaillon comme Valence c'est que
ce sont pas des villes qui sont
calibrées au niveau de l'appareil
sécuritaire c'est-à-dire en terme de
commissaire ou de brigade de gendarmerie
pour faire face à une telle délinquance
tel que on peut faire dans les grandes
villes je sais pas si on l'évoque
maintenant mais sur la réponse policière
vous prenez par exemple vous prenez par
exemple Marseille Nice ou une on y
reviendra mais parce que c'est
intéressant parce que la stratégie en
fait quand la dame dit il y avait des
signes avant-coureurs il y avait des
armes de guerre qui circulaient il y
avait des vengeances ou des sortes de
Vendetta qui étaient menées et qui
faisaient l'objet d'une publicité pour
faire une rivalité entre les gangs si
j'ose dire locaux on voit que l'appareil
sécuritaire et la réponse policières et
judiciaire en fait et complètement
adapté par rapport à cette seconde on va
regarder un reportage à Besançon mais
juste sur les trafiquants et les
consommateurs Michel Gandillon pour
qu'on comprenne bien est-ce qu'il y a eu
un déplacement des grandes villes et un
lieu vert ces petites villes et versets
villes moyennes ou ça s'est ajouté
est-ce que ce sont d'autres
consommateurs d'autres trafiquants
de ville russe et des jeunes qui sont là
de depuis des années donc qui ont grandi
dans la vie et donc qui comme dit
Monsieur vu qu'il y avait un marché en
développement et qui sont qui ont créé
leur propre point de villes et puis on
peut avoir des partenariats
effectivement parce que les points de
deal qui s'installent dans les villes
moyennes ont besoin de substances donc
effectivement il s'approvisionne
notamment dans les grandes métropoles où
il y a une offre de gros très importante
par exemple je regardais le cas de
Valence qui est placé sur une artère
essentielle l'autoroute ou remonte la
résine de cannabis ou l'air de cannabis
qui vient d'Espagne et donc Valence est
située entre Grenoble
Montpellier et la région lyonnaise qui
sont des centres de redistribution des
drogues donc effectivement ces petites
villes moyennes sont placées à proximité
de grandes zones de redistribution donc
il est très facile de d'accéder à ces
substances il faudrait parler aussi de
l'offre mondiale et européenne qui est
considérable en ce moment il n'y a pas
que la demande il y a une offre aussi il
y a des records de production mondiale
de cocaïne
l'Espagne est devenu un énorme
producteur d'herbe de cannabis donc
effectivement les substances ont plus
que jamais accessibles et disponibles
c'est le cas juste aussi de ville oui
vous êtes aussi sur un axe qui favorise
l'implantation
luxembourgeoise beige sur le chemin ce
qu'il faut dire aussi parce qu'on le dit
pas suffisamment assez les consommateurs
sont les complices des dealers
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y avait une
réponse pénale qui a été inadaptée on
avait une justice qui était débordée
avant vous risquez un an
d'emprisonnement et 15000 euros d'amende
c'était le code de la santé publique
lorsque vous consommiez du stupéfiant la
fraction aujourd'hui elle existe
toujours mais en réalité quand vous êtes
prémodelinquant ça veut dire si vous
faites prendre pour la première fois où
vous n'êtes pas connu de la police la
gendarmerie vous êtes majeur qu'on vous
remplit à certains nombre de critères en
fait c'est une amende de 200 euros et on
a simplifié le travail des policiers des
gendarmes mais finalement au risque de
ban réaliser l'usage de la drogue et
aujourd'hui on a des consommateurs qui
ont du sens sur les mains puisque si on
a une telle offre dans les quartiers et
notamment aujourd'hui dans les
territoires les plus éloignés qui
étaient avant pas en proie ces
trafiquants c'est parce que on a une
consommation de plus en plus forte et
donc aujourd'hui on peut pas épargner
les consommateurs d'une grande
responsabilité dans cette Afrique dans
cette trafic ce qui est trop le cas les
consommateurs
quand on parle par exemple de
légalisation vous voyez bien que
l'actualité récente malheureusement nos
collègues à Roubaix Manon Steven et Paul
ses politiques ont été tués à
Villeneuve-d'Ascq quand on fait les
frais on veut banaliser la drogue on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui le cannabis
suffit plus la cocaïne se démocratise
donc finalement si on ouvre la voie une
drogue on ouvrira la voix toutes les
drogues et quand on voit que aujourd'hui
on a une telle banalisation de la
consommation de stupéfiants en France
moi demain pour mes enfants pour vos
enfants ce qu'on veut c'est une société
apaiser c'est pas une société qui est
droguée et qui est sous anxiolytique ou
qui est Sud drogues de synthèse nouvelle
qui font des ravages dans les
populations les plus jeunes
consommateurs
mais même dans le discours parental
enfin moi j'ai des enfants qui ont l'âge
je disais de l'auteur des faits qui les
ont côtoyé puisqu'on nous sommes tous
dans cette petite ville et quand
j'entends autour de moi certaines
personnes certains parents disent oui
mais ce fait tout le monde fume fume du
cannabis entre autres ou voilà non je
pense que c'est enfin dans une forme de
banalisation nous avons en fait c'est
pas grave si ça reste grave alors il y a
le côté effectivement trafic vous l'avez
exprimé mais il y a le côté il y a le
côté médical et santé publique on voit
bien qu'un consommateur qui démarre
quelquefois c'est peut-être qu'il y a un
trouble de santé aussi de santé mentale
de bien-être enfin il y a des choses il
faut absolument qu'on s'attaque à la
racine de ça vous avez parlé de la
justice il y a aussi tout ce qui est le
volet prévention le volet santé mentale
et on peut déraper à de
l'hyperconsommation peut basculer dans
des troubles psychiatriques on voit des
consommateurs réguliers qui à un moment
donné bascule dans la schizo et puis
arrive aussi à des gestes inconsidérés
ou sous l'effet de la coque peuvent
faire des peuvent avoir des actes hyper
violents alors qu'il les aurait
peut-être pas eu s'ils étaient non
consommateurs donc moi je crois que lui
il faut il faut absolument pas banaliser
la console il y a une trop grande
banalisation de la consommation de
drogue aujourd'hui
nuance parce que il y a consommateur et
consommateur il y a aussi la
problématique des addictions il y a des
centaines de milliers de gens qui ont
des vrais problèmes d'addiction donc
c'est on n'est pas dans des
consommations récréatives donc il y a
une réponse en termes de de prise en
charge des addictions en France qui a
été un succès d'ailleurs dans les années
deuxième moitié des années 90 avec le
développement des traitements de
substitution à la méthadone qui a permis
d'enrayer l'épidémie d'héroïne donc il y
a eu la création dès que ça pas il y a
eu un certain nombre de structures de
prise en charge le problème
effectivement c'est les consommateurs
récréatifs mais il y a un phénomène de
déculpabilisation puisque maintenant se
développe beaucoup les livraisons à
domicile qui sont adossés souvent à des
gros points de deal on démantèle
aujourd'hui et des structures de
livraison à domicile qui sont capables
d'alimenter
des centaines de clients par mois qui
réalisent des chiffres d'affaires
énormes donc la culpabilité qui pouvait
y avoir effectivement d'aller sur la un
point de vie les entretenir une économie
dont sont victimes effectivement
aujourd'hui en France des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui vivent dans
ces territoires sous contrôle du crime
organisé donc cette déculpabilisation
finalement elle fonctionne plus et ce
qu'on voit c'est que ces livraisons à
domicile se développent beaucoup elles
se sont développées avec le covid est
bien sûr ça ne pourrait pas se faire
sans les réseaux sociaux est-ce ça s'est
développé beaucoup pendant le covid et
ça va se développer encore plus parce
que si les réglements de comptes
continuent de se développer sur les
points de Deal ça va être dissuader des
consommateurs de se rendre sur ces lieux
et donc les gens vont s'arranger
effectivement pour recevoir la drogue
chez eux dans le cadre effectivement de
cette tendance générale de l'économie à
l'amazonisation voilà on se fait livrer
ça sa pizza son CD ses courses et
pourquoi pas les drogues aujourd'hui
Véronique c'est aussi ça il aussi le
rôle des réseaux sociaux il y a aussi
une autre manière de de consommer de
dîner une autre manière ils sont plus
plus spécialistes que moi sur le sujet
visiblement oui non mais je pense qu'il
y a une autre manière de consommer de
toute façon les les consommateurs vont
s'adapter bien évidemment repousse un
point de villes on va le repousser plus
loin enfin c'est pour ça que je pense
quand même qu'il faut voilà il faut il
faut réguler aussi ça à la base et puis
moi je crois qu'il faut protéger les
enfants quoi de tout ça donc vous avez
raison tout le monde ne devient pas des
consommateurs brigands ou truants mais
on voit bien qu'il y a une partie de la
société qui seradicalise quand même sur
le sujet et les violences enfin moi
c'est hyper choquant d'en arriver là
quand même et on va voir qu'elle peut
être la réponse policière justement on
va aller à Besançon ou depuis 10 ans le
trafic de drogue et les règlements de
compte entre bons rivales sont en plein
essor une brigade spécialisée de police
a été mise en place dans l'un des
quartiers particulièrement touchés de
cette ville cécile ticsou a suivi cette
brigade bonjour jeune homme
vous allez bien ouais on va faire un
petit contrôle de police et qui sur du
procureur je vais vous demander de vous
lever s'il vous plaît contrôler des
jeunes qui attendent c'est leur
quotidien
vous attendiez quelqu'un ces policiers
de la brigade spécialisés dans la lutte
contre le trafic de drogue patrouille
tous les jours dans la cité de la
Planoise à Besançon
trottinette
ici il connaissent personnellement ce
que l'on appelle les guetteurs
principalement des mineurs qui
préviennent les dealers de la présence
policière quel âge avez-vous
vous avez 15 ans alors vous retournez
monsieur et vous me présenter le contenu
de vos poches s'il vous plaît vous
vendez pas de
drogueur non plus
[Musique]
vous allez passer vos vacances ailleurs
l'objectif pour les policiers et de ne
jamais laisser tranquille les
trafiquants on est vraiment pour faire
du harcèlement les empêcher de se mettre
en place
identifier les individus
les faire déplacer de manière à ce que
en fait les les individus prennent pas
position ou ne prennent plus possession
des des immeubles comme dans ce bâtiment
inhabité ou pendons des mois acheteurs
et vendeurs se retrouvaient cet hiver
et puis on les a on les a tapé une fois
ou deux et puis après ils ont décalé en
fait ils sont mis dans les garages qui
sont juste à côté avec les consignes les
tarifs ici
puis les petits mots doux pour pour nous
ce travail d'usure et de connaissance du
terrain porte ses fruits en quelques
jours grâce au travail des 12 agents de
la brigade la police de Besançon a
démanteler plusieurs points de Deal dans
le quartier
républicain d'aujourd'hui sur une
affaire qui a été réalisée où ils ont en
fait identifié un appartement nourrice
qui a amener à la à la saisie donc
d'un kilo et demi d'héroïne de 500 g de
cocaïne et de une importante somme
d'argent il y en a pour pas loin de 2000
euros mais surtout de deux cinq armes
car la police de Besançon doit aussi
gérer une autre conséquence du trafic de
drogue les règlements de comptes et les
violences entre gangs qui ont tué ces
derniers mois trois personnes dans la
capitale franc-comtoise ici c'est le
relogement de dealer d'un autre quartier
dans la cité Planoise qui a généré des
conflits
en apportant certains nombre de produits
aussi par exemple l'héroïne et la
cocaïne ce qui a généré certaines
tensions en fait entre les entre
guillemets et les nouveaux arrivés du
coup des clans se sont constitués comme
c'est un trafic qui est très lucratif on
a eu des tensions qui sont apparues et
des règlements de comptes qui ont
commencé voilà vers 2018-2019 où il y a
une petite pause et où on a eu après une
résurgence de ces épisodes sur 2022
comme beaucoup d'autres villes moyennes
Besançon et gangrené depuis 10 ans par
le trafic de drogue c'est la situation
géographique frontalière de la ville qui
intéresse les trafiquants
alors on le voit Mathieu Valley il y a
une brigade spécialisée qui a été mise
en place à Besançon est-ce que les
policiers ont suffisamment les moyens de
lutter contre ces trafics d'abord merci
de montrer que la police de proximité
n'a pas été supprimée et qu'on a des
policiers qu'on appelle dans les
Brigades des policiers qui sont
fidélisés sur des territoires très
compliqués ce qu'on appelait les
quartiers de reconquête républicaine
avant les zones de sécurité prioritaires
c'est des territoires délimités par
l'état où on estime qu'on a perdu du
terrain en terme de valeur en termes de
fonctionnement en termes de respect des
autorités et des instances de l'État et
donc en fait c'est policiers de la
brigade etc tous les jours pilonnent les
points Dean on a une première stratégie
qui a porté ses fruits et dont il faut
féliciter des policiers légendaires
c'est que tous les jours les dealers
chaîne des murs et les policiers
tiennent le terrain c'est ce qu'on a vu
dans votre portage et en fait on
grappille finalement chaque jour du
terrain face à ces dealers en faisant
des belles saisies à Marseille par
exemple il y a eu encore récemment plus
de 200 kg de résine de cannabis et de
productions qui ont été faits notamment
dans les quartiers nord on voit que
c'est CRS c'est policiers de la Sécurité
publique pile en permanence les points
de vie sauf qu'aujourd'hui ça ne suffit
plus il faut qu'on mette le paquet sur
la police judiciaire parce que
finalement on coupe les pieds et les
mains mais on ne coupe pas les têtes
alors
police sur le terrain c'est une question
de réponse judiciaire derrière une fois
que les policiers ont fait l'intérêt
il faut être faire très court mais je
parle des grandes villes puisque là
Besançon la planète c'est un quartier de
reconquête républicaine par exemple
villeuru n'est pas en quartier de
reconquête républicaine et la difficulté
dans les petites et moyennes villes
aujourd'hui touchés par les trafics
c'est que la présence de policiers et
gendarmes n'est pas au même nombre que
celui des grandes villes ou des grandes
agglomérations des grands ensembles et
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui l'appareil
d'État l'appareil policier judiciaire
doit s'adapter à cette nouvelle
délinquance puisque finalement on a des
trafics à l'identité des grandes cités
ou des grands ensembles mais qui a pas
les mêmes moyens policiers ou même moyen
judiciaire que ces grands ensembles et
ses grandes cités et là où j'évoquais la
police judiciaire c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les têtes de réseau les commanditaires
sont souvent à l'étranger à Dubaï en
Arabie Saoudite dans les pays nord du
Maghreb qui comme on dit et qui dirige
les trafic parfois même aussi depuis la
prison et que finalement la police
judiciaire en démontrant les gros
réseaux robonner les gossasses quand on
parlait tout à l'heure de ces véhicules
qui remontent de l'Espagne pour pouvoir
alimenter le marché français on a
uniquement par exemple la brigade de
recherche et d'intervention où toutes
ces unités spécialisées de la police
judiciaire qui ont le temps qui ont les
moyens qui ont la spécialisation de
pouvoir éluder ces enquêtes aujourd'hui
et j'en terminerai l'un on a la réforme
de la police nationale et il faut faire
attention de pas dézinguer cet outil
judiciaire qui est une plus-value énorme
pour lutter contre les mafias contre les
gangs contre la criminalité organisée
quand on voit les Pays-Bas quand on voit
la Belgique quand on voit l'Italie on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui ce qui manque
assez pays c'est cette excellence de
l'outil d'investigation que représente
la spécificité de la police judiciaire
française
municipal de virus est-ce que les élus
ont les moyens il y a des policiers
municipaux mon imagine que c'est pas
suffisant en face ces trafic de drogue
moi j'étais conseiller municipal
d'opposition en fait sur cette ville
mondial en termes de moyens policiers
nous on a un réel souci on nous manque
des effectifs mais c'est largement connu
depuis longtemps la rue enfin ça c'est
dit on nous une vingtaine de 78 à 95 20
policiers
nationaux en fait aujourd'hui on a des
brigades de gendarmerie qui ont été
votés par le Parlement de la création de
200 brigade de gendarmerie dans la
ruralité ça pour vous ça rappelle en
fait si on est en réalité donc on est
sur une on est sur une une
circonscription police on est à côté
d'une ville qui est sur une
circonscription gendarmerie qui est d'un
autre département parce qu'on a en plus
on a cette difficulté d'être en inter
départementale donc ça ça pose aussi la
question de la réorganisation en fait de
la sécurité police gendarmerie sur un
territoire de vie parce que le bassin de
vie c'est une ville Meurthe-et-Moselle
une ville Moselle même nombre
d'habitants une et en zone gendarmerie
l'oté en zone police et on a le
Luxembourg à côté donc en fait voilà et
nous on est nous sommes rattachés à une
ville Longwy qui elle a le commissariat
principal avec des effectifs aujourd'hui
de 78 actifs policiers actifs on devrait
être à plus de 90 visiblement j'ai pas
les chiffres exacts donc quand on quand
on veut mettre une patrouille et on a
d'autres quartiers compliqué
Mont-Saint-Martin on a des quartiers
compliqués donc quand on veut déléguer
une patrouille quand il y a une
patrouille ils sont deux mais s'il y a
un problème qui se passe sur la ville à
25 km my repart et en fait voilà on sent
bien que le terrain est lâché on avait
un commissariat initialement autonome il
y avait 44 personnes sur la ville
vous avez raison en fait des villes
comme Oyonnax ces villes comme par
exemple villeuru les villes qui sont en
fait comme Montargis en réalité il
suffit parfois de 15 ou 20 policiers
pour qu'on puisse faire revivre ces
services de sécurité publique et mettent
plus de bleu sur la voie publique après
j'ai toujours que avoir plus de
policiers genre sur le terrain c'est
bien mais mettre plus de délinquants
derrière les barreaux c'est mieux parce
qu'on constate que la majorité des faits
sont commis soit par des multi
récidivistes ou soit par des personnes
qu'on connaît que trop bien et que
finalement on patauge dans la semoule à
interpellé toujours les mêmes qui
repasse toujours devant la justice
ensuite quand je disais que la réponse
elle devait être pas uniquement sur le
terrain vous avez aussi et
malheureusement les petits témoignes ont
été oubliés vous prenez Nice avec la
carte des moulins ou l'Ariane vous
prenez Montpellier avec la Paillade vous
prenez Marseille avec les quartiers nord
vous prenez la Duchère à Lyon ou tous
ces territoires connus pas
malheureusement faisant par l'actualité
on a mis des compagnies républicaines de
sécurité des CRS à demeure pour appuyer
les policiers locaux et faire de ce
qu'on appelle du pinage de point digne
aujourd'hui au delà de pilonner les
points deal et libérer ces choses dire
les habitants de la joue de ces
trafiquants il faut pilonner les réseaux
et pilonner les têtes de réseau et on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui là où on a un
bac qui blesse fortement c'est le
blanchiment d'argent et tous les biens
mobiliers immobiliers et tous ces
comptes bancaires qui sont à l'étranger
donc on a du mal à récupérer l'argent
même si avec les groupes d'intervention
régionaux ou avec les saisies à des
avoir criminels c'est à dire vous savez
c'est ce qui a été mis en vente aux
enchères à Bercy il y a pas longtemps
c'est tous ces saisies qu'on fait sur
les opérations de police les comptes
bancaires les objets de valeur les
véhicules de luxe etc on a encore
beaucoup d'efforts et beaucoup de marges
de progression pour taper au
portefeuille ce qui fait aussi mal que
la prison
est-ce que c'est aussi une réponse
politique une réponse démocratique
j'allais dire est-ce que cette extension
du trafic de drogue dans les petites et
moyennes villes c'est aussi la
conséquence d'une perte d'autorité de
l'État un certain quartier à l'échelle
de l'Union européenne ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il y a une prise de
conscience notamment avec la présidence
tournante suédoise et six premiers mois
de l'année sur la question du crime
organisé il y a pas qu'en France
Monsieur a parlé effectivement des
Pays-Bas de la Belgique qui s'inquiète
de leur devenir de narcoetta il y a eu
un rapport du Sénat de la dégréation
parlementaire au renseignement qui parle
de menaces en pleine expansion donc qui
pose des problèmes stratégiques pour la
sécurité publique pour la pérennité de
l'État dans certaines zones
effectivement qui sont contrôlées parce
que la différence a effectivement entre
l'ancien milieu criminel qui est bon
toujours existé en France notamment à
Marseille le milieu corso marseillais
c'est les contrôles de territoire et
l'assujettissement effectivement des
populations qui vivent et c'est un
scandale démocratique et puis il y a les
capacités de corruption le marché des
drogues en France aujourd'hui selon
l'Insee c'est 5 milliards d'euros 4 à 5
milliards d'euros il a doublé en 10 ans
donc c'est des sommes considérables qui
peuvent effectivement contribuer à la
corruption des lieux municipaux de
magistrats de Pol enfin il y a des
affaires de corruption y compris donc
effectivement c'est une menace trop
organisé de trop grande ampleur pour
aujourd'hui pouvoir lutter où il y a des
moyens de lutte bien sûr qu'il y a des
moyens de lutte par exemple il y a
l'exemple de la loi de 70 du 31 décembre
1970 qui a été mise en place pour lutter
contre les filières corso marseillaises
déjà de l'héroïne qui ont durci
considérablement la réponse pénale et
qu'on dissuader un certain nombre de
parrains du trafic d'héroïne savoir que
la France à l'époque était un des plus
grands producteurs mondiaux d'héroïne de
rentrer parce que le jeûne n'en valait
plus à chandelle avant la loi de 110 un
fabricant d'héroïne à Marseille pouvait
se prendre 5 6 ans de prison après la
loi 110 c'est 20-30 ans de prison donc
il y a une question de la réponse pénale
et du renforcement aussi de de des
magistrats et des enquêteurs qui
travaillent sur ces dossiers qui sont
relativement complexes parce qu'ils sont
internationaux avec des ramifications
dans le Maghreb je pense qu'il y a une
spécificité de territoire on voit bien
il y a des très gros trafic il y a des
bandes nous on a un territoire en fait
qui est hyper spécifique je pense que
chaque situation doit s'analiser au
prisme de ce territoire et du type entre
guillemets de banditisme ou de
consommateurs qui a nous c'était pas du
grand banditisme par contre on est sur
une ville où on n'est pas on n'a pas de
quartier reconquête républicaine on a
pas de qpv on a pour autant il y a des
poches de pauvreté à côté d'une ville
comme le Luxembourg ou la moitié de la
population travaille au Luxembourg donc
augmente les revenus moyens alors qu'on
a une poche de pauvreté énorme qui
cohabitent et puis voilà je crois qu'il
faut vraiment arriver sur les
territoires moi je crois qu'il y a des
moyens quand même elles doivent être
locaux je crois que les communes les
interco doivent s'y mettre aussi
nationaux la justice et effectivement la
sécurité et on pourra pas se passer
européenne quand on voit que le Maroc
est le pays producteur exportateur de
cannabis au monde quand on voit que la
cocaïne arrive par les portes d'Anvers
Amsterdam ou du Havre on voit
aujourd'hui comme pour l'immigration
clandestine comme pour le terrorisme
qu'il faut une réponse européenne et
aujourd'hui on a aussi un back qui
blesse parce qu'on a beau avoir européen
ances policières qui coordonnent des
actions de police on a encore beaucoup
de marge de progression aussi sur ce
point là merci beaucoup
[Musique]
et Audrey au quotidien reviennent sur
les agressions dont sont victimes les
élus oui Presse Océan évoque évidemment
l'audition au Sénat du préfet de
Loire-Atlantique après la démission du
maire de Saint-Brévin le préfet
reconnaît un échec collectif prend sa
part mais assure que l'État a été à
chaque fois au côté du maire des
violences contre les élus qui
n'épargnent aucun territoire c'est ce
que nous rappelle l'Alsace des maires
des conseillers municipaux font face au
quotidien à des doléances quasi
diffamatoires conséquences les élus
suivent des formations dispensées par la
gendarmerie pour gérer les incivilités
l'actualité c'est aussi le pouvoir
d'achat qui préoccupe toujours les
Françaises que nous rappelle le courrier
de l'Est même si l'inflation a ralenti
en mai les prix du beurre et du lait
font l'objet de toutes les attentions et
l'une des conséquences c'est la baisse
des dons aux associations la baisse de
la qualité des dons aux associations 70%
des dons fait au Secours populaire ne
sont même pas mis en rayon car trop
abîmés et dans ce contexte certains
modes de vacances ont du mal à passer
les vacances de l'indécence titres même
la Marseillaise dans le viseur entre
autres un projet can Island deux étages
de barres un restaurant une piscine
l'équivalent de quatre terrains de
volley vous l'imaginez ça fait tester
dans la région pour plus de simplicité
Oriane vous pouvez vous diriger vers la
Côte d'Opale La Voix du Nord nous
rapporte que 34 plages sur 44 ont une
qualité de l'eau excellente et puis je
terminerai rapidement si vous voulez
apprendre ce que veulent dire quoi
couper creej où il y a air et ben je
vous propose de lire la Provence qui est
fait tout un dossier sur les nouveaux
mots des adolescents c'est passionnants
c'est à dire
par exemple crise ça veut dire crime
voilà d'accord je fais ce petit mot
rapide
et merci Michel ah voilà
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
merci Audrey on se retrouve demain et
puis à 18h vous avez rendez-vous avec
thomannique bonne journée à demain
[Musique]